bonjour à vous merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur arte france alors après les
propos du président turc la france a
donc rappelé son ambassadeur
jusqu'où peut aller cette escalade
verbale entre les deux chefs de l'état
oui moins qu'on puisse dire c'est que
effectivement le contentieux s'alourdit
il y avait eu un précédent concernant
les attaques ad hominem c'était quand la
mi septembre le président r 2 1 avait
dit macron n'est pas fini d'avoir des
ennuis avec moi et là effectivement on
ose d'un cran dans les invectives parce
que c'est tout la formulation n'a rien
évidemment de diplomatique et elle
traduit une dégradation continue des
relations entre paris et ankara depuis
depuis plusieurs mois on pourrait dire
depuis la fin de l'année 2019 avec une
succession d'une succession de tension à
la fois par rapport à l'engagement turc
eux à l'extérieur mais mais aussi par
rapport à des enjeux de politique
intérieure liées à l'islam en france
emmanuel macron qui estime que le
président turc alimente la haine à
l'égard de la france
comment vous interprétez justement les
aînés font attitudes et les propos du
président turc
il ya le contexte de la loi sur le
séparatisme qui va être examinée le 9
décembre prochain
d'ailleurs ça fait ça fait prolongement
d'un discours qui s'est tenue le à
mulhouse le 18 février dernier par le
président macron qui évoquait justement
le problème de l'islam politique en
france et donc les la suite des
événements la dégradation intérieure va
c'est en france alimenté effectivement
l'urgence d'un certain nombre de
dispositions à caractère législatif et
réglementaire et le président et redonne
un souffle sur les braises d'une
certaine manière en instrumentalisant la
communauté turque en france de l'ordre
de 700 me de personnes dont la moitié de
nationalité française mais il ya aussi
dans la part du président turc un enjeu
pour lui
géopolitique c'est à dire de se
présenter comme le leader une certaine
manière de l'islam européen d'ailleurs
il ya eu des tensions avec l'allemagne
également dernièrement et il se trouve
que la france avec
revendication de la laïcité évidemment
le noyau dur de la critique du président
horaires d'orane qui veut d'une certaine
manière se présenter que le défenseur
non seulement des turcs mais des
musulmans plus généralement et et les
conséquences économiques justement de
ces tensions diplomatiques
voilà il ya une logique d'affichage
largement puisque vous avez évoqué le
cas du koweit et du qatar notamment ce
qui n'est pas anodin puisque le qatar
est quand même s'inscrit dans l'arc
tue-le on va dire l'alliance
turco-qatarie par rapport à la question
de l'islam politique donc c'est pas
forcément un hasard s'il ya
effectivement c'est une forme de boycott
des produits français
de manière générale ce boycott est assez
limité pour l'instant il ya beaucoup de
musique d'affichage mais sur le fond ça
soulève beaucoup de question
effectivement et notamment dans le
contexte national parce que les enjeux
sont aujourd'hui considérables après
l'assassinât du professeur sa mère
pattie et on sait que la perspective
justement de changements réglementaires
et pouvoirs législatifs concernant
notamment les imams détaché en france
constitue un enjeu crucial
et ça concerne tout spécialement les tur
puisqu'il ya à peu près 150 imams
détachées turc et que la turquie est un
des pays les plus réticents à accepter
effectivement la révision de certaines
de ses dispositions sur le
positionnement de ratchet tayyip erdogan
quelle est votre analyse il se pose
comme le défenseur aujourd'hui de
l'islamisme dans le monde
oui il ya l'idée de présenter d'une
certaine manière le leadership sur
l'islam sunnite
ça et ça ça sous-entend aussi une une
rivalité avec l'arabie saoudite qui est
avéré aujourd'hui et qui renvoie à la
crise avec le qatar donc la cuisson en
2017 et l'expression donc il ya
effectivement une fait un positionnement
résolu à mener aux ottomans on va dire
de
2 du président turc parce que il a des
difficultés intérieures pour le coup et
donc il ya une mobilisation sous forme
islamo nationaliste qu'ils exportent
aussi à l'extérieur et qui le conforte
dans son statut personnel
par ailleurs c'est vrai que la france la
turquie s'opposent sur d'autres dossiers
il ya aussi la libye le karabagh là
encore c'est cette dégradation des
relations que l'on observe entre paris
et ankara s'inscrit dans une continuité
comment ça peut évoluer oui oui il ya
effectivement à l'interface internes
externes et j'ai évoqué la dégradation
des tensions qui remontent à fin 2010 9
qui est l'opération tueur dans le nord
de la syrie contre les kurdes qui quand
qui était l'allié effectivement sur le
terrain dans la lutte avec la coalition
contre deich vous avez eu une ingérence
de plus en plus marqués effectivement à
tripoli ou de la turquie qui a fait
basculer les choses sur le sur le
terrain militaire
il ya eu des tensions évidemment très
fortes en méditerranée orientale qui ont
justifié le soutien de la france à la
grèce un soutien d'ailleurs qui a pris
une forme militaire donc courant de
l'été et puis dernièrement les
accusations par le gouvernement français
et du président notamment de de l'envoi
de mercenaires dans le conflit
concernant le nagorny karabach et donc
tout ça effectivement alimentent cette
dégradation continue des relations entre
ankara et paris merci beaucoup à david
rigoulet roze je rappelle que vous êtes
chercheur associé à l'iris rédacteur en
chef de la revue orient un stratégie